let's talk about the next episode
because we see a Brittany meltdown and a
Billy Lee explosion it looks like so
what can we expect I'm sure a lot of
people saw on social media of when the
original fire was posted Billy wasn't
tagged in the photo and she took that is
you left me out I'm the only trans girl
and then made it a transphobic thing and
it just got so blown out of proportion
when in reality it was ariana a nice job
to pass on the information about girls
night and then come Monday it's posted
on social media and Billy's like so you
guys left me on I was like Ariana I
thought you were gently just like I
thought you were telling her we're like
oh my god it was our fault and then
Katie got all of the blame and it was so
unfair but she pulls her fat heart I
will hold my trans car Billie was always
included so it was something that got
blown insanely out of proportion and the
Britney thing I know man I'm already on
the brim of like freaking out there was
more going on than what it looks like
there were some personal things filming
stuff that it was just it was a bigger
thing that couldn't completely be told
so that's her story to tell but it was
it was a lot I think she was just
feeling a lot of wedding pressure and
like well what about this cj1 and she's
like oh my god I just got engaged like
let me enjoy this first back and there
was just a lot of pressure on her at
once there's always more to the story
yeah alright if you had to describe with
one word what is still to come this
season how would you describe it um well
you'll see more dating from me because
there's another guy you'll see we're
gonna date with later on you'll see more
of me Adam you'll see how this all plays
out towards the end of the season we do
a girls trip to Solvang we go
wine-tasting I think that we'll probably
coming up in a few episodes we go back
to Mexico we went to Puerto Vallarta and
that was the best trip this group has
ever had it was such a good group who
won and it was so much fun
Jackson Britney's engagement party
there's a lot for me there I asked you
for one word you gave me
I don't know I've one where I explosive
I don't know why it's just a lot to look
forward to
[Music]